願望が実現したらどうするんですかね？みんなやることなくつまらないでしょうね
世間ではそうなんですよ
やっと自分の夢が叶ったら
それからやることなくなっちゃいますね
しかし 仏弟子たちはそうじゃないんです
願望が叶ったところで
あの宿題をするんですよ
人間としての もうもうアサインメント
人間としてやらなくちゃいけないことを
やるんです 恵まれた人のつの行い
それまたです 恵まれた人の行い
一 受用之楽 汗を流して正当な方法で財産を得た仏弟子は
一 自分自身の面倒を見て楽しむ
いわゆる金でよく食べて
もう高価なもの 服を着て
結構贅沢するということなんです
食べ物には 私はこの米食べませんよとかね
こういう米でなければ食べませんよ
金があるんだから大丈夫でしょうに
自分が食べる米のためには
まるっきり農薬を使わない土地を五
六年ぐらいもう土地を調整していれば
その米だけしかしか食べませんよと
わがまま言ったって大丈夫ですよ
金があるんだから だから自分が楽しむんですね
二 両親に楽をしてあげて養う
自分が頑張って 俺が頑張って金儲けたんだからね
お父さんお母さん出ていってくださいとはないんです
一生懸命両親にも楽をしてあげるんです
だから両親がすごく楽しく生活すると
これすっごい楽しいんですよ
やってあげた人にとっては
いかに気分がいいか 例えば豪華な家で
これはうちの息子の家ですけどとかね
この老夫婦が自慢げに家にいると
いかに楽しいかと その頑張っている息子にも
もう全然もういくらでも頑張れるんです
両親が喜んで 自分が作った家に住んでいるんだから
で そういうことで両親を養う
三 妻子使用人に楽をしてあげて養う
当たり前のことですね
子供たちにも奥さんにもすごく楽しく楽をしてあげる
それから自分の使用人たちにもすっごい気分よく
あ この人のところで仕事できてよかったよかったと思えるように楽しくして楽をしてあげるんです
四 親友たち仲間にも楽をしてあげる
それから自分の友達やらね
一緒に仕事をする人々やら仲間やらね
みんなとも仲良く楽しくパーティーやったり
いろいろやったりして
そのお金を十分使う これ全部もうとくとん儲かったお金使ってくださいという意味なんです
これが正しく財産を受容
受容したことなのです
だから金儲けて使いなさいよと
どんどん使いなさいと言ったっても
道があるんです このつのチャネル使いなさいよと
一つ 自分が楽しむために
2番目 親を楽しませるために
3番目 妻子やら使用人を楽しめるために
4番目 友達 仲間に そのつのチャネルでお金を使ってくださいと
そうすると あなた正しくお金を使っている
恵まれた人の行い二 財産の確保楽
苦労して正当に得た財産であっても
火災 水害などで亡くなったり
政府泥棒に取られたり
嫌な人に強引に持っていかれたりする
財産は儲けたんだけど
なかなかいろいろ攻撃来るんですよ
ね 火災に遭ったりとかね
災害 水害にあったりとか
あるいはね もう時々もうかなり罰金やら政府もね
あんた税金払ってない
あれやこれやと言ったりして
もう出した資料を認めないんだとかね
勝手に向こうはもう評価したらもうどうにもならんですよ
訴えたってももうもう勝てませんだから
だからまあ政府に取られたりもするし
それから盗まれるし まあそれからもうよくここら辺でいろんな東京で商売やってるとこのいきなり来るでしょ？ヤクザの人々とかね
来てお金出せとかね 何の代わりにお金出すんですかって聞いたっても
出なきゃ商売できないんだよとかね
何もやってくれませんだけど
お金持っていかれるんですね
だからそれはもう嫌な人に取られることなんですね
そのようなことで財産がなくならないように適切な対策をとる
見てください ブッダの智慧がね
お金出て入ってきたら安心するなよと
もの...問題が起こる前に
お金をしっかり確保しておくんです
問題が起こる起こる前に
しっかり誰にも取られないようにと
財産をどう踏ん張っても
これが邪魔だよと 財産の確保できたことで
仏弟子は喜びと安心を感じるんです
それからすごく安心しているのです
恵まれた人の行い  ３ 義務を果たせる
だから財産は安心だ なくならないんだということで
ものすごく落ち着きますよ
すごく楽しいんです それから
３番目の楽しみは 伝統
文化 習慣などによって生じる様々な義務があるんですよ
いくらなんでも皆様は日本人だから
日本の伝統文化 習慣があるし
もうアメリカ人だったらそちらの伝統習慣も変なものね
ハロウィンとかね もうそういうものもあるし
それぞれ国によっていろんなものがあるんだからね
これちょっと変になっちゃって
日本人がハロウィンやったり
向こうは日本の文化をありがたがったりとかね
まああべこべですけど
まあとにかく まあイカれてる人の喋ってることじゃないんだから
日本人なら日本の文化伝統を守るのは当たり前ですけどね
一人もいないんだけど
まあだからそういうことは我々の生きている上の義務があるんですね
この義務はお釈迦様は ５つにしているんです
一 一 ニャーティバリー
親族に対する義務 二 アティティバリー
来客 旅人に対する義務
で これは皆様ちょっとわからないでしょうね
おそらく まあ来客には来たらそれなりの義務があるんですね
面倒見てあげなくちゃいけない
インド文化ではそれもっと問題大きいんですよ
インド文化では この旅するのは宗教の一貫している一部なんです
旅に出る人は何も持っていかないんです
宗教道具だけ持って出て行ったんです
それで 1年  2年  3年  5年
6年  10年旅するかもしれません
ヒマラヤまで登ってまた降りてくるかもしれません
何年かかるかわからない
それ宗教一貫 それで社会には義務があるんです
そういう修行で旅している人が見たら
家に来たら勝手に来るんです
何のことなく歩いていて
自分ご飯食べる時期だったら
そこら辺でどんな人の家にも行くんです
行ったらその家の人ははい
どうぞ座ってくださいと
もう顔を洗ったり体を洗ったりする用意をしてあげて
ちゃんとご飯食べさせて
今日は私はこっちで休めて
はい わかりましたと休ませてあげたりして
次の日にはその人は出ていくんです
だからそれやらないと神に対する冒涜だとヒンドゥー教で思っているんです
だから家に神が来たんだと
突然訪ねるんだと だから
その人にする接待は 自分が信仰している神に直々やる接待っていう気持ちでやる習慣なんです
日本ではそういう習慣はありません
だから国によって違います
しかし 日本でも来客はあるんですね
サンプッパペーとバリ
それは洗足用なんですね
それも国によって違います
だから我々は日本の洗足用の方法が正しいか
カンボジアの洗足の方法が正しいかと
そんなことを考える必要はないんですよ
正しいかろうと間違っていようとどうでもいいんです
それぞれの文化で洗足用という儀式があるんです
それをやらなくちゃいけないんです
4ラージュバリを現代で言えば政府ですねに対する義務
昔は王でしたけど 今は政府ですね
対する義務があるんです
5デーヴァダッタバリ
神々に対する供養  これも当然ヨーロッパにもあるし
日本でもありますね もう神々と日本で言えば神社でしょう
神社仏閣も至る所にあるんだからね
で やっぱりそのその地方では
その住んでいる人々はやらなくちゃいけないんです
この財産に恵まれた人は
この義務をちゃんと果たすんです
だから これ仏教徒に特別に教えた教えですけど
仏教徒は狭い人間じゃないんです
狭い人間になるなよと
ちゃんと義務を果たしなさいよと
例えばもう どんな人でも
日本人が仏教徒になったら
その日本人がこれから神社の祭りなんか絶対やるもんか
私は仏教徒やと そんなかっこ悪いことはしません
前前からやっていたら
そちらに行って参加して協力してあげて
お金出さなくちゃいけないんだったらお金も出して
それをやります 別に信仰変わったわけじゃなくて
自分の義務を果たしている
そういうことで仏教徒はだから社会に認められるんですよ
仏教徒であることは社会に迷惑じゃないんです
すごい社会にとって楽なんです
その 5つの義務 でお金があるんだから
その義務を果たせますよ
で 4番目 最後の義務 恵まれた人の行い
お布施ができる楽 これが仏教徒にだけしかできません
汗を流して正当に得た財産がある仏弟子は
心を清らかにした また
心を清らかにするために精進努力する出家に対して
死後幸福をもたらす功徳になるお布施を行うんです
修行する出家者にお布施するとすごい徳が貯まるんです
それでものすごく死後幸福になるんです
聖者に また聖者になる道を歩む人に施しができることは大変な幸福なんです
お布施できるんだと 自分にはお布施したくてもお金がないんだったらどうしますかね
この 1 コップさえも持ってない人はどうやって大さじ1つあげてもいいと言ってますけど
この 1 コップさえ持ってない人はできないでしょうに
財産がなければ布施もできません
だから財産を得たことで
そうやってかなりの社会が助かるんですよ
これは法則なんです 私は前見せたでしょ
ある人がどこかの学校に
子供たちに何とか楽しく
例えばすごい寒いところで
政府はもう暖房なんかにお金を出してくれないし
子供たちはいっぱい服を着て毛布までかけて勉強する
これかわいそうやの 勉強できないで
じゃあ私は 100万円ぐらい
みんなと協力もあって
学校に暖房設備作ってあげようではないか
あるいは冬の間では暖房に使う費用をね
燃料値上げましょうと
それには百五十万ぐらい必要だなと思って喋ると
何のこともなく百五十万さっさと集まるんです
俺が百五十万欲しいやと思っちゃうと
1円もくれないんです
だからよく覚えてください
金が入る法則っていうのは寄付に施しにあるんです
だからお釈迦様が人生
最期 人生全体的に施しの人生にしてあげたんです
施しの人生になったら
もう豊かで豊かで もうもうむちゃくちゃ豊かになるんです
財産の正しい使い道 財産に恵まれた人は以上の 4つの行いをするならば
その人の財産が正しく使用していることになるのです
喜ばしいことです あの義務 4つですね
行い 4つ  4つにも金がかかるんです
自分が制作しようと思っても金がかかる
子供に家族に楽をしてあげようと思っても金がかかる
神人のお祭りやろうではないかと思っちゃうと金がかかる
全部金がかかる道なんです
戦争費用にも金がかかる
しかし これ金がかかる正しい道なんです
正しくお金を使っているのです
無駄に使っているないんです
無駄に使ってはない だから
あ お金あってよかった
ちゃんと使うことができたと
いう すごい喜びが生まれるんです
なんてよかったと この 4つ以外
いかなる方法で財産がなくなっても
それは不正に財産が消えたことなのです
悔しいです お釈迦様がおっしゃったあの 4項目以外
お金使うと あれは無駄にお金がなくなったなと
それで 今日から皆様もお金は使うでしょうし
この使うお金がお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
4項目に入るようにと気をつけてください
4項目に入らないものはダメです
無駄です はい それで経典は全部終わりました
で  4つの願望があって
その 4つの願望が叶うために 4つの方法がありますと
その 4つの法の 4番目だけは 5つに分けてあったんです
分けてもまたまとめて
この 5つが心に入らんようにしてください
それで 4つのこの資本的なエネルギーがついたら
商売はうまくいくんです
長生きもできるんです
殺生しないと長生きできます
殺生しないと決めたら
それから酒を飲まなきゃね
麻薬とか当たり前に で
長生きもできます 何でも叶います
それから得たお金を 4つのチャネルで使う
そういうことで 経典はそれでなおさら覚えてほしいんだから
忘れて困るんだから お釈迦様は数字で言って終わるんじゃなくて
歌で締めるんです 大体
この経典は歌で詩で終わるっていうことは
もうあの長い文章を忘れられ
覚えられないんだったら
歌だけ 詩だけ覚えておきなさいということなんです
だから長い経典なんですけど
ほんのりみち ほんの身近な芸人
またまとめる ブッダ ボーガ
バタ バッチャ ヴィティンナ
アパダ スミ ウッダッガ
ダッキナ ディンナ アトー
パンチ バリイカタ 意味
祭りを授与しました 養うべきものを養った
危険から財産を守っておいた
功徳になるお布施を行った
また  ５つの義務も果たしましたと
これ喜びを表しているんで
やったそうと だからお釈迦様はこういうふうに喜びなさいよという
この万歳の文句まで教えてあげているんです
ウパッティタ シーラワントー
サンニャタ ブラフマチャリアヨー
ヤダッタ ボーガン イッチェイヤ
パンディトー カルマワサン
ソーメアットー アヌッパットー
カタン アナヌターピア
梵行を守る 心を制御した戒を守る
出家のお世話もできました
いわゆるちゃんとした出家で
いい加減金儲けに出家したわけじゃなくて
ちゃんと修行する目的で出家する仏弟子だということなんです
私にはそういう人々の仰せできましたと
理性の在家が期待願望する目的に達しましたと
在家として達するべきところに達しましたと
ということは成功しました
希望が全部叶って 悩むことはあり得ないようになりました
もう悩むことってさっぱりないんだと
悩める羽目になるものは全部もう取り消してるんだよと
財産は確保しているわ
出家者に施いて だから四
五天国に行くでしょ で
もう大丈夫だと ちゃんとお金払って自分も贅沢してきたし
家族などなど 親戚みんなにももう楽しませて楽し楽をしてあげたし
もう何が文句あるのかと
私の人生では それは仏教徒の人生なんです
何も文句はない 悩むことはないと
完全安全だという生き方
エータンアヌッサランマッチョーハリエダンメーティトーナルーイダチーエナンパサンサンティーペッチェサッペッチェサッゲーチョモーデティー
聖なる教えに従った人は
このように自分の成功を思い浮かぶ
ああ 成功した 成功したとよくよく思い浮かべ
楽しいんです これがこの世でも讃嘆される
死後 天界に生まれて なおさら喜びを感じる
だから私は最初にちょっと欲が深いなと言っても大丈夫です
お釈迦様がこの世で豊かに生きていて
死後天国にも行けるという道をちゃんと教えているんです
はい これで終わりと思います
以上 ブッダに説かれた人生を大成功に導く方法です
それ以上もないし以下でもないんです
これは完全たる教えです
で それを聞いたら アナータビンディカさんがね
そういうなら私に全部揃ってるんだよと
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている理性な在家ではないか
私はと思うでしょ その人はそれを全部叶えていたんだからね
だからお釈迦様の説法だとまずいな
これやらなくちゃとかね
ちゃんと五戒守り まずいな
明日から回らなくちゃって気持ちないんです
アナータビンディカさんが全部守ってるんです
だから説法を聞いては
あれ お釈迦様おっしゃっているところは全部あるんだ
ああ 私は良かったんだ
すごく気分気持ちよく家に帰られます
はい それで経典は終了します
質問とかあったら出してください
はい